por 569 mil contagios y 18.000 decesos
en un país de casi 12 millones de
personas hacen de túnez el segundo país
más afectado por el cob y 19 en áfrica
los doctores están perdiendo las
esperanzas en el sistema de salud
tunecino pero estamos acá por nuestros
pacientes y tratamos de hacer lo mejor
que podemos en el primer caso de
coronavirus se registró el 4 de marzo de
2020 desde entonces los contagios han
aumentado sin control colapsando
hospitales y morgues
yo sé a veces tenemos entre 13 y 14
cuerpos al día pero sólo podemos
realizar 9 entierros diarios que es lo
máximo que permiten los protocolos
frente a la crisis sanitaria ha cobrado
el cargo de ministro de sanidad a 6
personas el más reciente
howse y mehdi fue destituido la semana
pasada la llegada de la variante delta
que desde finales de junio causa entre
150 a 200 muertes diarias hace que la
cuarta ola del virus sea la peor hasta
el momento según our world in their a
825 mil personas han sido inmunizadas
por completo en el país sin embargo el
presidente de túnez caixa y aseguró hace
unos días que en las próximas semanas un
total de 5 millones de tunecinos serán
inmunizados en la actualidad en el país
rige el toque de queda hasta el 31 de
julio entre las 8 de la noche y las 5 de
la mañana están prohibidos los eventos
sociales deportivos y religiosos aunque
los ciudadanos no lo respetan mucho ante
la crisis españa francia italia china y
arabia saudita donaron vacunas y
material médico